hello everyone and welcome to the
highlight show of class chess
international my name is Santa Barbara
Hyman and I'm going to take you through
the key moments of day eight so today
unfortunately was the final day of class
chess international and the champion was
crowned if you watch my video yesterday
you should know that this was a match
the finals were a match between Magnus
Carlsen and Fabiano of Caruana
so coming into today thick players were
tight it was a very close match and I'm
not going to tell you who won the
tournament in case he doesn't know not
to spoil it for you
so we'll cook a game by game and you
will find out who won the tournament at
the very end so with that said let's
jump right into it and let's take a look
at what happened today so let's start
with our very first game so far beyond a
karana with the white pieces it was a
rustling mouth so let's start with the
key moment in this game so in this
position
Fabiana plays a move that brings a rock
into the center which looks like normal
looking wolf but actually doesn't really
do much because there's this really nice
tactical shot in the position before and
you'll understand why this is a nice
move as I show you what happened in the
game so pawn takes and now 95 so when we
go back just one move we'd realize that
black does have pressure on this F file
and the Queen on g5 can may be a little
annoying this may be some kind of rope
g3 ideas at some point but white is
hanging on and the main issue for black
is this Knight is just completely out of
the game and the white is ready to kick
this rock out at some point and with
this movie for now we see that night
becomes a very important piece a very
important attacker and this bishop
actually becomes useless because the
Bishop e6 was played but let's say
Bishop goes to d5 while it's a very
nice-looking face it's not actually
doing anything okay so let's take a look
at what happened in the game so we
should be six and Fabiano decides to
sacrifice an exchange because it's hard
to suggest a good move for him rook f1
looks like a natural move to defend this
guy but it runs into some unpleasantness
I'm just winning the Queen
okay instead Bishop i5 is play takes
takes and Fabiana put up a lot of
resistance in this game so kudos to him
for that and this is something that very
good players are really good at that
just keeping the game going and not
collapsing and you know just making
moves making your opponent making their
opponent rather keep making decisions
keep you know having to come up with
winning ideas or good moves and you know
the longer you keep the game going when
you're on the losing side the higher it
higher your chances of modding the
waters or at least increases the chances
of your opponent making a mistake
so f4 so we go for this endgame Rocko
started to take on g6 d5 is a really
nice move just breaking apart this whole
situation that White has going on and b6
is another nice move going after this b2
pawn and I so check out this part he
gives up his rook but he's going to to
win an exchange from by promoting this
fun so by Vanegas route to six so this
was another way of giving up the rook
you could have gone rogue team on and
done that so he decided that this pawn
might fall and he wanted to keep this
pawns
so King comes here so this is quite a
long game and I just want to show you
the endgame of Bishop versus rook so I
think here Fabiano could have put a
better defense has his Bishop landed on
this diagonal and you will see why and
this is what Magnus is doing is not
letting the bishop get on the diagonal
now pushes the pawn pushes the pawn one
more time stopping the bishop from
getting on the diagonal and check this
part out as of course King c2 is
impossible
the pond Queens looking Gators plate
King III and now tomatoes another
inevitable
so one were try by Fabiano and of course
not rookie one which would have been
stalemate and I guess it's also worth
showing that looks it is also still made
not something a world champion would
fall for I wrote you ten resigns in view
of checkmate is coming the next move
so nice wind by the world champion wins
the very first game starts the match off
on the right foot leading the leading
the match and winning with the black
pieces so we're gonna have a couple of
key moments here so let's jump to the
very first one so the last move white
plays rook c2 and the move makes a lot
of sense the rook is trying to go here
to double on a file fight for the file
and try to try to penetrate from the a
file and the next move is one of my
favorite moves in this round and this
tournament actually because it's just
such a sneaky move I'm gonna place King
Jade which kind of feels like it doesn't
know what to do so it's just moving back
a part of the king
so microscopes work a to following up
with this plan so take stakes
unfortunately this is a blunder because
takes take and d4 and the reason your
King needed to be on g8 so there is no
route k7 check so just imagine this
position with the king on g7 and this
wouldn't work because check and then
take on d4 so I just love this King G
because this is such a nice trap and
kind of you know like hard hard to think
of it as a trap because it's such a
passive mode yeah so you could see on
camera how annoyed Magnus was that he
missed it and it was very clear that he
realized that he missed it after he
played it and this is one of the fun
things about online chess you can really
see the players reactions because there
have more of a poker face when they're
playing in a tournament home because
they're actually physically facing their
opponent but online it's a lot more
emotional and a lot more entertaining so
t3 and of course black piece on the
better end of this and should be close
to winning but there is no really
cut way of ending the game let's take a
look at how the game continued so
pushing the pun all the way to d2
keeping an eye on the rope
so Magnus decides to give up this punt
to open up his queen and give himself
some perpetual ideas so let's keep going
so the King comes out so in this
position he played king g6 and the
computer suggests something that most
humans wouldn't go for I think giving up
this pawn and taking on before and the
king can actually run to the Queen side
and this one is defended by the Queen so
it's very convenient and your pawns are
a lot faster because if you already have
a pawn on second ring so of course that
helps but I think this is very hard to
do with little time on the clock because
you know feels like maybe you're letting
it go and also feels like you're kidding
you're giving your opponent a lot of
chances since that King g6 was played
some lot of back and forth and Fabiana
was very long time and unfortunately for
him as we are nearing dance I can you
hear spoiler he was not able to find a
breakthrough so this game just continued
until it ended in a perpetual I'm not
sure if either player realized because
when you're playing in a time scramble
sometimes you don't but you know the
computer automatically ends that game
and it's a threefold repetition because
by the rules of chess in a three-fold
the game ends so big miss by Fabiano
karana he could have came back the very
next game like he did yesterday after
each game he lost yesterday he won the
very next game and tied the match as a
big miss and you know four games left
tilt clutch games in a hand in a head so
the match is still very close so this
game we're gonna start on move 23 so
Fabiana captures this punt so this is so
we got here from a rustling mo again I'm
not focusing on the openings because
we're trying to see what happen in the
game not learn opening so do some kind
of a theoretical discussion so so Magnus
actually played before here so here is
he this was his missed opportunity he
played he should have played at five
given up this pawn and some kind of move
let's say chases night away so the
knight doesn't want to take this bishop
and end up in a classical that Bishop
versus a good night but instead the
knight is going to move and compared to
the position look at this Knight on v6
or it can come back to life attack the
pawn let's go back to the position look
at this Knight one it just doesn't have
a future so even if I start moving it it
will require it so many moves to improve
this night and even if you make all this
move see it's not clear like why this
Knight is even had it so here white is
just dominating so it defends the pawn
goes back with the bishop puts the
bishop on a diagonal so five Magnus
decides to give up the exchange because
otherwise the rook is coming the knight
is going to have five just completely
dominating this efore pawn is going to
hang maybe you can to some rock lifts
and try to attack say decides to give up
the exchange so let's check out the
technique so exchanges this guy's wins
another pawn and black is stuck with
this terrible bishop
okay so let's just check out what Bobby
is doing so puts the King to safety
breaks through on the other side of the
board and the point is to go c5 okay
this could have happened the move before
so we'll have a similar position and
check out how safe the king is on h1
against against this Bishop on the
diagonal okay so f4 takes takes the pawn
and crucial move by Fabiano koruna which
he finds it rookie six and these checks
are not very scary because we can block
check exchange so it gives a few checks
here and the pawn is going to queen
something like Quincy two doesn't help
because we can check and trade Queens
and so something we don't see very often
two points on the world resigns in view
off if check I will run there's no Queen
g1 check because the rooks covering and
I just run and okay we have two queens
on the board
rule number two player will manage so
game three Fabiana karana with the
comeback the match is tight today score
is 1 I have 1/2 total score is five and
a half and five and a half alright so
this is the final game before the clutch
games and again if you're not too
familiar with this format I will explain
what the clutch games are but let's move
on to game four and I was thinking like
I've seen this before and then when I
looked it up this was actually an
opening from their World Championship
match if you watch that World
Championship it was the game where
Fabiana could have worn with this Bishop
Knight versus Bishop or Bishop Knight
versus Knight position when he had this
like Knight h1 backwards move and some
kind of a million 38 that you know only
computers could find I think it was game
6 of the match so 94 was played so in
the magic
went back 94 and a game he played c6 so
it's very hard for me to really
understand what's happening here and I
don't think this recap media can do
justice to complications I'm sure he has
an idea it's something very crazy that's
going on
so taking doesn't help because Knight c3
and this night is ours okay I'll give
you this night back I'll be up in
exchange where's the compensation and
it's just not there instead there's
another idea of if we go here to play 94
but even here I'm just a little unsure
of what's going on if Bishop d3 let's
say so let's say you want to defend this
guy right so I want to take on 92 so if
I just pass the move or if I cancel then
take Knight see through rookies trapped
so we don't want that so let's say we
defend like King do you want and I'm not
sure what's going on in this position to
be completely honest like the reason I'm
going to fall and this Knight is our is
why it's blocks this night is going to
be taken at some point and the two
bishops are quite strong the pawn
structure is bad the King is sketchy in
the middle of the world so I think this
is playable but also possible for white
instead of go back to my lines not here
after 94 there's also night here and
that a3 is hanging so there's some kind
of a mess that needs to be analyzed
that's a real strong engine maybe the
final conclusion is that white is just
better and like white should have gone
for that but over the boards in a quick
game maybe it's a difficult decision to
make so instead he takes a knight and he
goes for this Badger pawn structure okay
so I'm going to play through this move
until we reach our next crucial moment
because this is a again long game and
I'm not here to discuss the openings so
b3 King T 1 which is a
never really interesting with defending
this policy to basically saying and I
create a weakness but so what
and bringing the rook into the game so
both players are improving their
position I always love a rock lift so
takes so the better try would have been
maybe taking on b7 but again that leads
into some complications after let's say
take and this Bishop is stranded here so
you cannot go here because take take
take there goes the knight not something
to do so efficiently for which really
relieves the pressure and puts the
worstest allows Fabiana to put the worse
behind him so we go down to this end
game takes this pawn more exchanges
Bishop on the Ignite ideal but good
enough so this is all ok g5 and a huge
mistake by Fabiano karna playing at 5 as
he had already like escaped this you
know stop position that he had like ok
the opening I don't know what could
happen in the opening the middle game
was kind of tough for him and this is
escaping he makes this big mistake and
rug before it's so disappointing to to
lose like this when you're defending and
you think like things going your way and
then just wondering one move
so takes takes and the problem is there
is this distant past pants so wide it is
going to distract black with this past
file and just come and take all these
guys so this guy is already hanging so
if f4 and the bishop will come around
and take this and now this one is
actually super dangerous because you
cannot even get to it so instead King b6
was played and just takes all the puns
so I will quickly show how the game
ended
thanks and resins so we don't even have
to worry about not this bishop this
bishop on this square you know when in
Bishop and games we always look when
there's a corner pawn well it's like
that's the bishop match the corner but
it doesn't matter cuz white will just
put upon an f5 on this pond will Queen
there's just no way of stopping it so a
really heartbreaking loss for five and
okarin after that great win in round
three even I even got the match so now
we enter the clutch games but Fabiano a
point behind so in the next two clutch
games the winners worth three points so
Magnus just needs to trust advance to
win the tournament and Fabiano needs to
score one and a half okay so let's jump
into a move twenty so we got here from
another Russell limo so in this position
white goes Knight be three so white is
up a pawn puts a knight on a five I
really like how Fabiana played this part
defending the rook bringing the Queen so
here he has some kind of a crazy line of
playing Knight b8 the idea being that I
think it's just impossible to find of
course if the Queen moves back we're
gonna take the route cannot take the
rook is hanging so if the Queen goes
here we have a fork and here there's
some kind of an insane line that no
normal human being would ever find but
it's just really fun so I have to show
it to you and just simply just shoving
this pond down the board at the point is
the root cannot move from the e-file of
the root move so we're gonna check on
mate and the thread is just gotta be 78
and Queen the pond so and then of course
there's this Queen v7 move d7 and not
the Rockies move again I'm just showing
you computer line and I'm just showing
you for entertainment because this
something like this could I don't think
would be found especially in a rapid
game
it's a threatening mate and afteri and
of course you cannot take
because there's a fork so the best that
the best move would be rooting it but
the point is there is no taking because
check but instead we can do this and the
root can not take because of me so again
this would never be found in the game
but it's I thought it was very pretty
and you know I did something I want to
share but let's move to the game Fabiana
played this position like a normal
person g3 which looks a little bit of a
scary move against this Bishop but this
Bishop is just so control on the 8/8 is
a pretty set Square for a bishop to be
so h6
it's a clearly black just cannot do much
putting tonight underneath seven was not
an improvement and we will see
and now finally night b8 so now the
Queen goes to d8 so we repeat once in
our Russian school of chess always
repeat the position and now simply takes
so here rook t1 would have been enough
to win the game but I love what Fabiana
did here 97 takes threatening the Queen
the Queen is pinned with the Bishop 96
the night is just capturing everyone so
the route cannot go back because of this
fork and otherwise this rook is hanging
so not afraid and just resigns because
okay we're going to take Roxy this
coming White is yourself - up up it's
right - rooks are already supposed to be
better than a queen and you had another
night to the equation so it doesn't
improve improve things were black so
what a clutch victory by five I know
Cara wanna you know going down in Game
four then coming back and winning this
game so now he's two points ahead of his
opponent so now we have one more final
clutch game but because the last game is
worth three points of Magnus Carlsen is
still in it he still has a chance to to
win and come back and a try is good
enough for Fabiana to clinch the title
I wanted to say a normal-looking
position but not quiet so why does have
the two bishops and tonight is kind of
funny here this bishop on the other hand
can be kind of annoying you know a lot
of dynamics in the position drugs are
coming to the center but the key thing I
think for what if it's a samurai's would
be the two bishops so if Magnus Carlsen
finds an amazing movie six
so maybe Fabiana didn't realize what was
headed his way so he takes the pawn he
should have played up six but playing up
six is really ugly allowing your
opponent to have this kind of passed
pawn so Knight g5 logical follow up
right attacking the pawn rook f6 a very
logical move defending the pawn and now
Queen c2 he he must have seen this one
he played e6 but what a concept
and you will see why so here he should
have played g6 instead he goes for up to
six which looks normal and throw g6
what a strike in the center the route
cannot move that's not the right
diagonal for ax okay I'm raking there is
horse cannot move rook cannot take the
rock because okay and sorry guys
struggles with technology because I'm
eight is coming and otherwise the Queen
just has nowhere to go what where to put
the Queen right Queen cannot go anywhere
to defend the rook the Queen has to go
back so we capture if something like
this happens and how do we stop the meet
now so the position is just busted
instead Fabiano decides to take with the
Queen but she doesn't have enough
because look at those two bishops when I
5
just takes the pawn bishop f8 what a
nice move threatening here here the
Queen I'm doing better with arrows this
time and there's just no mate so five
mana gives a couple of checks and the
game is completely over it because mate
is coming and he resigns and there's a
loss Magnus Carlsen with this clutch
victory to win the tournament so big
congratulations to Magnus Carlsen what a
comeback what a way to end the
tournament what a stunning stunning game
following a six in 695 with this Queen
c2 rookie six like what a concept a very
deserving winner
fabien like in a postgame interview if a
Brenna felt look very dejected he said
like he felt that he wasn't really in
this game at all and it does feel like
that because you know if we look at that
if you look at the games that happened
before this all the fight you know the
resources and then this game that was so
one-sided just really didn't go his way
but again kudos to Magnus Carlsen for
this big comeback so in the postgame
interview he did he said actually that
before this last round he wasn't too
worried he was quite relaxed because he
felt that neither player was able to
defend difficult positions well so he
thought you know he would get some
chances as long as he keeps the game
going keeps things complicated and he
wasn't really insulting his opponent
right he was saying like both of them
like couldn't defend that position so he
just thought if he gets a little bit of
an edge or like some complications that
he would be in a good spot and he was
asked and this is a quote that I really
like my race actually asked him if
winning this kind of clutch games is
like a weak quality or the defining
quality of a champion he said champion
should show dominance every time and
also dominance in crucial critical
moments so you know he just always wants
to be on top always supposed to be the
best so big props to him and
congratulations again to Magnus Carlsen
what a great finish just everything we
could have asked for
everything came down to these last two
games so thank you everyone for joining
us thank you for tuning in and watching
these videos I would if you haven't done
so I would suggest you check out the
first seven videos covering every single
name and of course you can look through
the games more thoroughly on us just
chance calm thanks everyone for joining
us